bien avant l'heure ils sont déjà là
devant leur établissement à trépigner
d'impatience
ils partagent leur ressenti et surtout
tentent de relâcher la pression car dans
quelques minutes ces collégiens de 3e
vont vivre le premier grand examen de
leur vie le brevet
grâce aux deux probables en est un peu
appris à apprivoiser le stress chez moi
je pense que je me sens bien
comment il est sorti lundi pour moi
j'étais déjà dans un esprit de vacances
donc du coup j'ai un publi de réviser le
lendemain c'est avec mes frères qui
faisait que jouer mais les mercredis du
coup j'ai quand même révisée je pense
que je vais me débrouiller surtout en
français parce que j'adore la
littérature l'orthographe et les maîtres
ceci je pense que ça devrait aller je me
débrouille aussi
finalement je reprends ce que j'y peux
je suis stressé de paris ici même si
j'ai appris par coeur par hauteur mais
j'ai pas confiance
est ce que finalement les parents sont
plus stressés que toi détendu sont très
détendus
au contraire il me disait mais calme toi
y'a pas de problème c'est rien et 8
heures les portes du collège s'ouvre
officiellement chacun rejoint sa salle
d'examen pour se concentrer un temps de
relaxation leur est proposé l'occasion
de revenir sur des exercices pratiqués
durant toute l'année en inspirant trois
fois inspire
expire
aujourd'hui 99 élèves passent le diplôme
national du brevet dans ce collège
ce matin mathématiques pendant deux
heures et français cet après midi la
préparation s'est faite sur toute
l'année avec des cours de renforcement
régulier et les élèves à besoins
particuliers ennuis de santé troubles
dys troubles du comportement aux
porteurs de handicap ne sont pas oubliés
cette année sur le collège nous avons
neuf élèves à besoins éducatifs
particuliers dont qu'ils ont tous remis
à temps c'est-à-dire un tiers de plus de
temps pour pour proposer ses antennes
des sujets à kandy ses antennes
descripteur des dotant des lecteurs donc
il est important de tenir compte de tous
ces aménagements pour que les élèves
réussissent est un des meilleurs
conditions
demain matin place aux épreuves de
sciences avec technologie et svt pour
terminer par histoire-géographie et
éducation morale et civique